[Music]
okay so I have one hand on my chest
other one on my
elbow
just
do where you
touch
it's
okay push and
push this one's
here not
here
and that's not you push like round push
like round and now now I'm already in
you see you see
that watch the difference you push you
and it's not in there yet you see it's
not in there what you can stay here and
I'll find
it so I didn't get my posture back but
look you see so it doesn't really have
to do with posture but when you cor when
you do your posture as you're getting up
to to do it you see you don't have the
connection so here I'm clearly in bad
posture okay but I'm going to change the
energy and here we
are
see
that's
in there in
there it's not me going
forward it doesn't have to be me going
forward you
push so I want you to train these
Corners one corner here elbow Corner got
it your job is to touch that every time
so it doesn't have to be like you go
that's got to be the yarm do you see you
can go the other
way you all your job is to push me over
that's your job not to take the Kev you
push me over that is the Kev push you
see
and then you change sides so I can work
both sides
both push you're not pushing me your job
is not to fall safely your job is to
push and on the outside there you go
right
okay you should try both angles so this
angle I'll try that angle or I'll try
this angle and you're going to change
hands again remember you're change every
time but I can go
back and go straight
back you can change the angle
see I can do a
delay it's in it's
in you're going to do it
quick you go want you want to play with
you're going to push both hands you
don't you're not falling very high so
you don't want to be afraid you're going
to push both
hands got it okay try it
again uh so this one he'll be at one
elbow that same elbow okay push the
elbow push the
elbow and this one's on my head
push push push I got this H back but
same thing Bo connection
projection same thing changes in in his
body and connection projection again he
goes you can Qui if you want you can do
it slow and get really low you're
in
it's not it's not about me
pushing you hear this is different right
W okay but watch he he still got drive
[Music]
and change all
angles you can't even go
back
okay
up push push pushing VI bre connection
you'll push through
me grounds his
energy
okay than
[Music]
try it again last
one don't don't get greedy at the end
there you go